XIAOHUI YUAN: Today we're going
to talk about numbers in
China and what sort of other
meanings it might be
associated with.
I believe the most famous
one would be number 8.
It's serious stuff, because
people are willing to pay a
fortune to get as many 8 on
their registration numbers for
their cars, on their phone
numbers, work out how to have
a child on the right date
and in the right
month with number 8.
This is number 8 in
Arabic numeral.
And in Chinese, it
is just that.
BRADY: Oh, that's
pretty simple.
XIAOHUI YUAN: That's
That's the simplest
one, probably.
People love it.
Everybody wants to be
able to write it, so
they keep it simple.
Number 8 is pronounced
as "ba" in China.
The pronunciation is very
similar to that of "fa," which
means getting wealthy.
Like, this is "fa." This
is "ba." This is "fa."
For example--
[SPEAKING MANDARIN]
--means, wish you become
really wealthy.
So they're making
loads of money.
Doesn't matter if you
become a fat cat.
So to encode, to symbolize their
wish to get wealthy,
just in a very simple manner,
like on their registration
numbers for the car and
their phone numbers.
So they just love to use
the number eight.
And I have the tendency-- if I
look at a car in the street
and pay attention to the
registration number, if
there's one with particularly
a lot more number 8's than
normal cars, I would tend
to look at the driver.
And 9 out of the 10
times, it would be
an Asian-faced person.
Or Asian person.
Asian-looking person.
Sometimes if you want to book a
particular table in a really
posh, expensive restaurant--
like I want table 8.
Or when somebody gets engaged,
the bride-to-be's family would
expect number 8 is involved
in a certain way.
If it is not, they
will get upset.
People are very much
hooked up on it.
Chinese people, you know,
historically, the average
people have struggled a lot
over thousands of years,
because there's almost a
straight transition from a
feudal society to a Communist
society, where always a large
number of population and
limited resources.
Everybody wants to become
wealthy, important, have a new
life, have a better life.
Therefore, this number 8 kind
of symbolizes every--
or if not every, most Chinese
people's dream to have a good
life, to have good luck, to
have quite a few money in
their pocket.
BRADY: You live in England
at the moment.
XIAOHUI YUAN: Yeah.
BRADY: Do you still have a funny
thing about number 8, or
have you been shaken
out of it?
Or do you still find
8 special?
Is it ingrained in you?
XIAOHUI YUAN: I--
I'm normally not that
much fussed by it.
But when I go buy a lottery, I
sort of would prefer number 8
on it, either 8 or
18, 28, or 38.
As long as there's an 8 on it.
BRADY: Is the number 88
considered especially lucky?
XIAOHUI YUAN: Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
88, 888, 8,888.
If a bride-to-be at an
engagement party received
8,888 yuan from the groom-to-be,
that's very
pleasant and expected
very much.
We also have another special
number which is associated
with good luck and associated
with "things will happen
smoothly." It's number 6.
This is 6 in Chinese
character.
And we also have traditional
Chinese characters which
indicate 6, which is normally
used in very formal occasions,
like on a check or
on a property
title deed, which is--
BRADY: So that's a more
formal number 6.
XIAOHUI YUAN: Yeah.
Yeah.
Number 6, its pronunciation is
liu, which is very similar to
another Chinese character
indicating good luck, which is
[SPEAKING MANDARIN].
6 is liu, and good luck, things
happen smoothly is liu.
BRADY: That's the same!
XIAOHUI YUAN: Yeah,
that's the same.
Just the tone is different.
Normally, people like number 6
to be involved before they go
on a journey, before
they take a flight.
They hope everything would
go smoothly when
they go on a cruise.
So 6, liu, really means
something--
everything will happen or turn
out to be fine, so there's no
unpleasant surprise involved.
While 8, number 8, fa, is
specifically associated with
getting wealthy.
BRADY: You've told me that
people in China prefer the
number 8 to the number 6.
XIAOHUI YUAN: Yeah.
BRADY: Does that mean
they would rather
be rich than lucky?
XIAOHUI YUAN: [LAUGHS], looks
like money is the first
priority of people's concern
in China, certainly.
BRADY: Do people in
China realize that
666 is a bad number?
XIAOHUI YUAN: No.
In China, that's a very
lucky number.
BRADY: OK.
But they do know that Westerners
don't like it.
XIAOHUI YUAN: No, they're
not aware of that.
It's a very Western thing
about triple 6.
Yeah.
There is a number which could be
disliked by lot of people.
It's number 4.
Why is that?
It's also because of
the pronunciation.
Number 4, in Chinese,
is pronounced as si.
Another Chinese word, which
means death, is
pronounced as si.
So the pronunciation is
exactly the same,
apart from the tone.
A simple Chinese character for
4 and the traditional Chinese
character for 4, which
is used in formal
occasions like title deed.
BRADY: What does that mean?
Does that mean people
just avoid--
XIAOHUI YUAN: Oh, yeah.
BRADY: You can't avoid
the number 4.
XIAOHUI YUAN: Well, you try to
avoid as much as possible.
People would pay for
number 8 or 6.
Nobody would want to
pay for number 4.
And they try to avoid it as
much as they possibly can.
There's an anecdote here.
I have an acquaintance who's
got six 4's in his phone
number, and he was trying to
phone up for Chinese delivery.
And the lady, the Chinese lady
on the other side of the phone
would not take his
number down.
The lady took the
first number 4.
It was all right, 4.
When it's come to the second
one, the lady's
voice started to shake.
When it comes to the third one,
the lady asked, how many
other 4's you have?
He said, another three.
She said, I'm not going
to take your order.
I'm sorry.
It's just so unlucky
in Chinese culture.
BRADY: That was in the
UK, wasn't that?
XIAOHUI YUAN: That's
in the UK.
That's actually Nottingham.
BRADY: So if someone in China
had a whole bunch of 4's in
their phone number, would they
get rid of that phone number?
XIAOHUI YUAN: Oh, yeah.
They would definitely
try if they can.
Yeah.
They would complain to the phone
shop and swap to another
number, yeah.
BRADY: The r, the [INAUDIBLE],
is 200.
FEMALE SPEAKER: And this number
is called a googolplex.
BRADY: OK, [INAUDIBLE]
is 6.